my dear friend chers amis mesdames et
messieurs les députés
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
permettez moi de remercier le président
monsieur larcher et la présidence
française de m'avoir conviés à prendre
la parole ici aujourd'hui
ce ne serait pas exagéré que d'affirmer
que l'avenir de l'europe et pas
uniquement la destinée de l'ukraine et
du bélarus sont en train d'être
discutées et décidées aujourd'hui même
hier la fédération de russie et le
régime d'alexandre loukachenko ont lancé
un assaut à large échelle contre
l'ukraine
en réalité il s'agissait d'une attaque
contre l'europe toute entière nous
sommes témoins du plus grand conflit
militaire sur notre continent depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale à l'heure où
nous parlons les forces militaires de la
russie prépare une attaque contre kiev
des images nous arrive de l'ukraine
s'est véritablement des scènes dignes du
cinéma c'est difficile d'imaginer qu'en
2022 des individus en plein coeur de
l'europe doivent se cacher dans le métro
pour éviter les bombardements des
personnes qui doivent s'organiser en
groupes pour l'autodéfense territoriale
parmi ces individus il y à nombre de
ressortissants bélarus qui ont quitté
notre pays en fuyant la répression
bélarus une attaque contre lui rennes
l'ukraine pardon est en violation des
principes fondamentaux du droit
internationaux notamment le droit des
nations à s'autodéterminer le président
de la fédération de russie dans ses
nombreuses allocutions a dit les choses
très clairement il ne reconnaît pas que
ce soit la souveraineté ou l'état nation
de l'ukraine et du bélarus l'admirent
poutine estime que notre nation no
nation appartiennent à sa sphère
d'influencé
et cet état d'esprit aujourd'hui il est
obsolète puisque c'est un état d'esprit
qui nous ramène au passé à l'époque de
la guerre et des conflits
mon coeur est avec les ukrainiens et
l'ukraine aujourd'hui je sais qu'ils
luttent pour leur pays mais pour chacun
et chacune d'entre nous également c'est
un test majeur pour l'europe si l'europe
est à même de protéger c'est valeur si
elle ne permet pas à ses voisins d'être
abusés sans conséquence c'est seulement
ainsi que l'europe triomphera en effet
la revanche de la russie à l'heure
actuelle n'a pas de limite et je suis
sûr que si l'europe n'arrête pas poutine
en ukraine et bien peut-être qu'un jour
il arrivera aux portes de berlin ou de
paris mesdames et messieurs le bélarus a
également besoin de votre aide cette
attaque contre l'ukraine n'aurait jamais
été possible si loukachenko n'avait pas
offert le territoire bélarusse à la
fédération de russie
en avec la mise à disposition notamment
des infrastructures et du territoire
c'est depuis notre territoire que des
bombardements sont lancés vers l'ukraine
s'est depuis notre territoire que les
hélicoptères russes et les jets de
combat d'école c'est depuis notre
territoire que les tanks russes sont
entrés sur le territoire ukrainien tout
simplement parce que c'est beaucoup plus
rapide de passer par le bélarus pour
arriver à kiev aujourd'hui bélarus et
sous l'occupation russe le régime chance
fantoche de loukachenko a remis la
souveraineté de du bélarus à poutine
contre le soutien de poutine en 2020 ce
qui a permis à loukachenko de rester au
pouvoir mais s'il reste au pouvoir s'il
contre il pense qu'il est au pouvoir et
qu'il contrôle la situation
or ce n'est pas le cas
nous le constatons dans la société du
bélarus seuls 12 % de la société du
bélarus estime que le bélarus doit
soutenir la russie dans la lutte contre
l'ukraine seulement 12% pourtant il n'y
a pas de manifestations de masse dans
les rues à l'heure actuelle peut être
vous vous demandez pourquoi tout
simplement parce que les voies qui
pourraient descendre dans les rues
aujourd'hui ont été supprimés oppressé
ou forcés à fuir le pagne le payer plus
de 50000 personnes sont détenues des
milliers sont devenus des prisonniers
politiques y compris mon mari qui a été
condamné à une sentence de 18 ans en
prison nombre d'entreprises de presse
des ong ou encore des entreprises ont
été expulsés ou intimidé le pays il est
contrôlé par la crainte et le régime a
l'impression de pouvoir agir en toute
impunité il a fallu neuf mois pour que
l'union européenne adopte les livres le
premier train de sanctions depuis 2020
et la plupart des dirigeants de
l'opposition étaient d'ores et déjà
derrière les barreaux après le
détournement de l'avion après la crise
des migrants le régime n'a pas eu de
véritable riposte c'était uniquement des
condamnations de la part de l'occident
ce qui a renforcé ce sentiment
d'impunité offert au régime la
possibilité de continuer de régner
aujourd'hui les bélarusses sont devenus
des cibles certes mais le continent tout
entier est une cible de la fédération de
russie ce dimanche un soi-disant
référendum doit se tenir au bélarus
étant donné qu'il y à la présence des
troupes russes qui sont présentés bien
c'est un grand problème
nous estimons que la crise ne peut
encore pas être résolus elle ne fait
qu'être encore plus renforcée la mise à
jour proposée par loukachenko dans la
constitution c'est de lever le statut de
neutralité et le statut de force non
nucléaires ce qui permettra aux forces
russes de continuer à utiliser notre
territoire comme un lieu où lancer les
bombardements ou occuper le territoire
pour ses attaques je vous invite
instamment à comprendre la chose
suivante lukashenko est une menace
contre la paix européenne au même titre
que le président de la fédération de
russie je pense que nous pouvons encore
stoppé lukashenko et poutine mais pour
ce faire nous devons agir avec courage
et agir ensemble
en premier lieu nous devons nous rendre
compte que notre super puissance c'est
la solidarité il est grand temps que les
nations d'europe aujourd'hui expriment
toute leur solidarité vis-à-vis du
peuple de l'ukraine et du bélarus 2e
point nous devons réaliser et que les
dictateurs on ne peut pas les rééduquer
l'expérience de la proche avec
lukashenko me fait penser que toute
tentative de paix avec lui à mener à
davantage d'impunité ainsi je vous
invite instamment a cessé de reconnaître
les autorités de minsk elles ne sont ni
légitime ni légale troisième point j'en
appelle à la communauté internationale
d'imposer le régime de sanctions le plus
fort possible contre le régime de
loukachenko et de le faire le plus
rapidement possible en effet des demi
mesures n'auront pas de véritables
répercussions hier après la consultation
avec les forces démocratiques du bélarus
j'ai déclaré que j'étais prête à
endosser la responsabilité de
représenter la république du bélarus et
le peuple bélarusse est de créer un
cabinet de transition qui inclura des
personnes du bélarus mais également des
personnes en exil afin que nous prenions
la tête du pays que nous l'emmenons vers
des élections démocratiques et vers
l'indépendance
loukachenko a abandonné ce rôle il l'a
sacrifié et il ne remplit pas ces deux
tâches il s'attache comme défenseur de
l'indépendance
les élections qui se sont tenues en 2020
le peuple bélarusse n'a pas voulu les
reconnaître et la volonté du peuple est
plus forte que n'importe quelle bombe le
peuple bélarusse appelle de ses voeux la
liberté et la paix et nous remporterons
ce combat avec votre aide avec votre
solidarité la justice et la liberté
prévaudront veuillez soutenir l'ukraine
veuillez soutenir le bélarus ne pouvons
pas permettre aux dictateurs d'écrire
l'histoire parce que l'histoire et
l'avenir c'est à nous qu'ils
appartiennent
vive le bélarus est vive l'europe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]